in an effort to avoid controversial
topics I will not be talking about any
children series authors or any big
budget video games instead I'm going to
talk about Ezra Miller and the DC
Cinematic Universe
sure this will be a drama-free
discussion
I do this to myself
[Music]
so yeah
I've been thinking about Ezra Miller
lately now that we have had the first
full trailer for The Flash and I've had
a little time to kind of sit on it I did
a reaction to it initially so if you
want my actual thoughts on the trailer
there's a link that's on the break room
of Geeks my secondary Channel if you
weren't aware of that and
um
it's a pretty good trailer
I mean part of its Nostalgia Michael
Keaton whatnot but like it's it's
selling a decent product
ah I don't know how I feel about going
to see it though
uh in theaters at the very least and
that pretty much largely has to do with
Miller in specific
now Miller has been in a lot of trouble
uh in the last year or so pretty much
they kind of went on a tear when they
were in Hawaii there were some issues
with the ionized family and whether or
not they had coerced
um the child of these parents who were
trying to get a protective order put
into place there were issues with their
residents in Vermont including it being
an unsafe environment for a woman who
was there with her kids and a whole
bunch of other stuff the short version
of where all that currently stands
because I'm not going to go over over
all of it again in detail is that
for all of the shenanigans they got up
to
pretty much everything has had the
charges either dropped or withdrawn from
the people initially registering the
complaint now reasons for doing that may
vary people may have just decided it
wasn't worth the bother in the case of
prosecutors they may have decided it
wasn't there wasn't enough evidence or
again you know Miller can afford
um some serious lawyers and so it's not
worth the expense of of dragging it
through the court system the only thing
that they appear to be answering to is
some of the stuff in Vermont those being
trespassing and burglary charges which
they appear to be taking a plea deal on
and they have also entered into some
form of uh rehab and mental health
counseling
which is good
because
it really seemed like they needed it I'm
not going to do an armchair diagnosis
I've made my complaints in other videos
about why I think that's very wrong but
I I think
I don't think anybody was surprised to
find out that uh they they needed some
mental health care now we don't
at least last I checked we don't have a
specific diagnosis for exactly what's
going on with them they may not have a
diagnosis yet either that might act that
kind of evaluation might even be part of
seeking help we don't know
that's not really what I want to talk
about though because with the trailer
now out because things have been quiet
for long enough that
DC felt they were comfortable starting
up the marketing machine again and
honestly this is pretty much what I said
was Warner Brothers absolute ideal
Fallout for this that they would stop
getting into trouble answer for stuff
that they couldn't just duck out on and
immediately go into some kind of rehab
or counseling or help
and that's what's happened this is
Warner Brothers and DC's absolute ideal
which now begs the question
are they going to keep Ezra Miller on
after
The Flash
because the word some months ago was no
no like first of all I know that a while
back the discourse was you should take
them out of the movie entirely you Fire
Johnny Depp from the third Fantastic
Beasts movie ah and I've discussed
before why that's nowhere near equivocal
Johnny Depp was a supporting part who
was let go after a week or two of
filming Ezra Miller is the lead and now
we know from the trailer multiple
versions of the lead he's in almost the
entire movie the idea of reshooting it
completely with another person they were
never ever ever gonna throw that much
money at it because the film was already
done and like there were reshoots but
the filming was done the effects were
being worked on that was never in the
cards to recast and redo the movie
realistically ever was that gonna happen
but it was an open question would Miller
stay on now with James Gunn coming on
board and making it clear that he has
got his own plans for what he's gonna do
it seemed like a pretty safe bet
especially in light of everything
Miller's gotten up to that they'd be let
go it was a perfect opportunity for
clean break
except
Warner Brothers never officially said
they would
no longer work with Miller
and James Gunn
has heaped a lot of Praise on The Flash
movie and like look a Flash movie might
be great who knows
but both he and Warner Brothers seem to
really be dancing around the question of
whether or not they're going to keep
Ezra Miller on
and it the very obvious conclusion to
draw from that behavior from that
reluctance to confirm yes we will do
more with them no we are not going to
work with them anymore
the obvious conclusion to come to is
they're waiting to see the box office
Returns on The Flash movie
and that's where I come to my discomfort
with going to the theater to pay to see
it
because I want to be clear this is not
oh God I said I wasn't going to touch on
this screw it I'm already in too deep on
this this is where I need to make a very
clear distinction between my concerns
with this situation and something like
anything Harry Potter related and have
that feeds back to JK Rowling
I think it's a very good thing
that Miller is getting help Miller's
Behavior was unsafe and erratic
but it was also unpredictable
and again that doesn't excuse it but the
reason I have my issues with rolling and
supporting of Harry Potter is that her
behavior is incredibly predictable
we know what she's doing with her time
and money and influence and clout
so if you contribute to those things you
are enabling what she is doing with them
which is transphobia
that's what she does
but with Miller
in theory and I like I'm gonna underline
that in theory you contribute towards
their work you don't know what they'll
do now their recent Behavior does bring
it into question certainly but it's not
the kind of certainty where like okay
financially and contributing to this
person contributes to to some very clear
harm which kind of no not kind of it is
it is the case with rolling the thing is
we need to write recognize that rolling
is actually a pretty rare case
I see people trying to equivocate all
other kinds of things but like rolling's
a very rare case of this is the person
who always benefits from these from the
promotion of this property and this is
what she's doing with the influence and
the attention and the money we almost
never have it that clear-cut it's not
that clear-cut with Miller
but I still have a discomfort
and
some of that is what I tend to refer to
as the uh factor which is where which is
where I'm at with say Kevin Spacey Kevin
Spacey was in some of my favorite movies
of all time The Usual Suspects is one of
my favorite movies I have not watched it
in years I don't know when I will be
able to If Ever I still have my copy of
it so that if I ever do decide to watch
it I'm not paying
to see it
but I can't watch that I can't put that
DVD in a player in good conscience
not because me watching it at home
somehow bolsters Kevin Spacey or Brian
Singer for that matter
but I do just feel about it regardless
so like there's a little bit of that
with Miller
but that's not the only thing that gives
me pause
because
if there continued work within the DCU
and at Warner Brothers is contingent on
the success of the flash which again we
don't know for a fact but seems like the
very safe assumption to make
then I don't know how I feel about
contributing to their continued
employment
there at this time
and I shall probably delve a little bit
more into that this is not about
canceling Ezra Miller at least it's not
for me other people might have their own
other reasons for not wanting to watch
them support them see this movie Etc I
speak for nobody but myself
I'm not trying to cancel anybody I think
to whatever degree Miller is currently
canceled
they did it to themself
but
the thing for me is that
if what they're currently seeking is
mental health
and if
a lack of support
and or the stress of the situations they
were in we're contributing factors to
their behavior over the past few years
then I think it's a really bad idea to
put them right back into that work
environment again
because if the flash does really well
Warner Brothers is going to want to
start using them again right away be it
in cameos like they had in Peacemaker or
be it in
fast tracking The Flash too
I again understanding that I don't know
what their diagnosis is and I'm
certainly not a mental health
professional but it strikes me as a bad
idea
to immediately
have them go back to work
and I think time off would be the best
thing for literally everybody involved
and I don't know how comfortable I am
contributing to the financial success of
a movie where that success might result
in somebody who
really should just be
um getting help
continuing to be employed
in a high stress situation because
making movies promoting movies
these things are really stressful
but at the same time there is the
general idea of don't people deserve
Second Chances now that conversation in
and of itself can be
a very loaded one and a very dicey one
to try and have with people because
I think most of us have certain things
for which we say actually no
no you don't get a second chance after
that
and for some people I don't doubt that
Miller has crossed that line somewhere
along the way
I'm not sure I'm there but then that
hits uh onto sort of my other issue with
Second Chances which is the principle of
Second Chances and what is usually being
asked for as a practical reality when I
see in conversations well
you know people should get a second
chance because very often when it's come
up in conversations when I've talked
about other people in the past be it
Johnny Depp Gina Carano Joss Whedon
you know this idea of well doesn't
everyone deserve a second chance
we for the moment
just roll with the idea of sure again
I'm not actually going to concede that
point because sometimes no but let's for
the moment assume that yes everyone
deserves a second chance
my issue becomes people getting that
second chance on credit
what I mean by that is basically
slotting them right back into the
circumstances they were in when they did
whatever it was that's everybody's
problem immediately and the second
chance becomes just don't do it again
except you put them right back into a
situation where they can do it again
you've enabled their ability to do it
again
and you've shown them
that there is not going to be an
immediate consequence you can say all
you want just don't do it again
but effectively nothing happened
what will always strike me as a much
more meaningful example for
someone who earned a second chance
is Robert Downey Jr and he stands as a
massive success story from someone who
had a lot
a lot of problems
and who was kind of shunted out of big
budget Hollywood for a while because of
those problems and not even necessarily
PR like
movies couldn't insure him that's
actually a really big issue with a lot
of these actors and this is this is a
big reason why uh actors with
um you know problematic histories
especially in terms of behavior will
continue to find work but in in
um
much smaller capacities in like small
tiny supporting roles
um because big budget things ensure the
actors so that if something happens
um there's it's covered by insurance but
the insurance premiums on somebody with
a behavior history like Ezra Miller has
now probably or definitely like Robert
Downey Jr had back say in the 90s
yeah it's not practical to give them a
lead role because the insurance is going
to be through the roof
and the result of that
was that Robert Downey Jr slogged for
years
in supporting roles in
roles that honestly to know
a the talent that he has always had but
also see what happened to his career
since Iron Man roles that you look at
and go he he was in that he did what
he was in the Shaggy Dog it seems
laughable
but that was him paying his dues
that was him showing
up to work on a regular basis proving
that he could stay out of trouble and he
had to do that
for years
that to me is the model of a second
chance being properly earned
as opposed to what I see so often
requested where you know a celebrity
does any number of things
gets caught
you know on a drug Bender
commits this crime breaks this thing
you know DUI you know all the this kind
of social media Gaff reveals himself to
be a racist to transfer what have you
when people ask for Second Chances
usually they're framing in the way of
let's not punish them
and that perspective of a second chance
is basically
just giving them a gimme letting them
take a mulligan on their screw-up
that's not a second chance to me and
that is unhelpful
I feel
but
I don't think it is an unreasonable
thing to say that Miller might be
capable of earning a second chance with
time time working on whatever it is
that's going on with them time working
in smaller parts smaller projects
supporting roles and showing that they
can stay out of trouble
for an extended period of time
because if the flash does really well
they're going to announce a sequel while
it is still in theaters and they will
start and they will want to start
shooting it within two years now two
years sounds like a lot of time but
given that Miller would have to be
involved in pre-production for
everything from costume fittings to
possibly even some input on the script
depending on how the development of that
goes
that's getting back to work pretty dang
fast
and I don't
think
that's a good idea
again I say that as someone who doesn't
know them doesn't know exactly what
they're going through I haven't
diagnosed them I don't know exactly what
their issue is maybe whatever it is
it it is workable within that time frame
maybe
I don't know
but I don't feel comfortable
contributing to them being put back to
work that fast
they don't feel okay about that is it a
good idea is a bad idea
I don't know
it's an uncomfortable one for me though
and I think
where I'm probably going to land on this
is that
I don't think I'm gonna see The Flash in
theaters and I don't love saying that
because like I said I actually really
like that trailer
I thought the trailer was great Michael
Keaton said I have Batman and I cheered
huh
especially if it's as good as
um the studio and James Gunner sang
that'll make it hard but I actually
think for my comfort level at least my
uninformed
Comfort level
I feel like the better thing to do is
would be to have it do decently but not
perform well enough to green light a
sequel and to cut Miller loose so that
they can focus on themselves focus on
getting their help
and they can find other projects Miller
is a talented actor they are I actually
haven't cared for too many of the things
they've been in that I've seen but they
are not untalented they got as far as
they did for a reason
but
I I think I think I gotta wait for this
thing to hit streaming or something
where I'm not just gonna hand cash over
um and where I feel like the success in
that particular venue is going to result
in and let's put them right back to work
I think that's where I'm at right now
I think the movie's probably gonna end
up doing well
and when it does I think there's a very
good chance they'll be retained and then
I think the best case I can offer is
that what gets announced is yes we will
do more with Miller but it's going to be
in small appearances and the flash
sequel is like four to five years away
maybe I'd feel a little bit better with
that but with everything up in the air
and not knowing what's going to come
next
I kind of don't want to touch it
again personal feelings this is not a
call for a boycott not a call for
cancellation this is just where I'm at
with my own personal feeling of whether
or not I'm comfortable
but I just wanted to talk it out what
are your thoughts on any of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it oh
uh keep in mind this is not me saying
that oh we should be sure Miller isn't
getting paid Miller obviously has enough
money to be hopping between states very
with great ease
I think they're covered financially as
is so I'm not worried about that
regardless so again as I said whatever
your thoughts are down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living
um I've had a bit of an uptick uh in
this past month and it is helping
a lot things are still tight and they
pretty much always are but it really
does help but even if you can't support
me that way not only is that like share
and subscribe stuff which you know about
you know YouTube there's links down in
the description for other projects that
I do things that I have available
whether it be my written work such as a
novel my play t-shirts
Etc take a look at it but
don't worry too much about it because
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore Zuma
fulla Tarak the thing that goes doing in
the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters emu
dalke Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
nobilax the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support
and if you want to get your name in the
credits check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]